assalamu alaikum
thank you for joining us on our latest
installment of zadil
authored by the late an esteemed scholar
of islam
we were we had reached a point where we
were discussing the way that the prophet
[Arabic recitation]
alaihi wasallam would recite the quran
and as a prelude to this
i'd to mention something that is
very important
it's a statement of the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam
it's collected by both bukhari and
muslim that he said
mayuri
whomever allah desires good for
whoever is essentially destined for good
and ultimately destined for paradise
allah will grant him understanding of
the religion
now what does that mean does that mean
that only scholars are
people whom allah has desired good for
no that's not what is intended what is
intended is that a person
not become acquainted with every aspect
of the religion of islam
though that is the ultimate of
blessing from allah subhanahu
wa'ta'ala
rather what's intended by this narration
as the scholars of islam have mentioned
is that if allah desires good for a
person
they will become acquainted with all
aspects that concern them
all aspects of his or her religion
of his or her worship of allah
which is particular to their set of
circumstances
right so if a person is a merchant
somebody who buys and sells then
if allah desires good for this
individual he
will open the gates of knowledge upon
this person
to become acquainted with the do's and
don'ts as regards to
the religion of allah in that particular
field
and so the reason for this
is that the worship of allah subhanahu
[Arabic recitation]
is something that allah has given
permission
i know that that's kind of an
interesting concept
it is the responsibility of everyone to
worship allah
yes but we have to understand that
one of the great honors that allah has
given the human being
is permission to worship him subhanahu
[Arabic recitation]
that he has been permitted to
consciously
exercise his or her free will to worship
the
the lord of the heavens and the earth
allah subhanahu wa ta'ala has said about
the masajid about the
mosques he says
oh he describes the masjid as
houses which allah has
granted permission that they be erected
and that his name be mentioned therein
and so the scholars of islam mention
that
when we worship allah when we worship
allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala we have
actually been given
permission to do so now what are the
implications
of that the implications of that
are that an individual
may not worship allah without
having permission
without having guidance on every single
thing that you do
this is more commonly known as worship
and customs
[Silence]
they say the nature of worship
is that it is impermissible unless
otherwise stated
now with regards to our customs
it is exactly the opposite what do i
mean by customs
what we eat what we drink how we sit how
we sleep
when we sleep what we do these things
that are customary
across all lines muslim and
non-muslim alike
right this is our customs as a human
being this is how you are
the natural state of our customs is that
everything is permissible except what
allah has prohibited
it's the opposite of worship so
anytime a person worships we say wait
stop right there do you have explicit
evidence for this warship if the answer
is yes
then that is what allah has given you
permission if the answer is no
then a person may not do it until he or
she is
positive that this is something that
allah has allowed
this is where the concept of innovation
comes from
that if a person worships allah in a way
that
allah subhanahu wa ta'ala has not
granted permission
this is what innovation is
and as the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam informed us
all innovation is rejected right out the
gates
now that is contrary to our
customs with the customs it's exactly
the opposite
allah doesn't tell us what to do right
he doesn't tell us what to eat he
doesn't tell us what to wear
he doesn't tell us what to drink
rather he tells us what not to drink
he tells us what not to wear
he tells us what not to eat right
and so this is taken from
the story of adam alaihissalam the
first story in the quran
allah tells adam with regards to customs
with regards to our nature with regards
to our customs
he says subhanahu to adam
live you and your spouse
herein in this paradise and eat from
anywhere you choose
but do not approach or come near this
one tree right it could be
one particular tree or a type of tree
so allah subhanahu wa ta'ala doesn't
tell him what to
eat he tells him what not to eat
now let's look at worship
when adam alaihissalam did what was
prohibited
he disobeyed
and he wished to seek forgiveness
he wished to repent well repentance is a
major worship of allah
and so adam alaihissalam
was instructed what to do
in that case and so allah subhanahu
wa'ta'ala says with regards to adam's
repentance
that adam received
words and instruction from his lord
and meaning he said those words as he
was instructed
and allah accepted his repentance
so we see now a contrast with regards to
what to eat what to wear our customs do
whatever you like
except for these things which are
prohibited
yet when it comes to the worship of
allah you may not do
anything without explicit instruction
and permission from allah
and so often times people don't know how
to learn
if we understand that learning how to
worship allah is so crucial
how do i go about acquiring knowledge
well this is an a topic which actually
many books from
times of ancient from as far back as the
second century after hijola
the scholars of islam have written books
on the methodology and the etiquettes of
seeking knowledge
and one of the questions that i get a
lot
all of the time a common theme and that
is
the question goes something this
or let me say let me give you a scenario
and tell me if this sounds familiar
you get this sudden urge
to learn you become
absolutely enthralled
with islamic knowledge
whether it be the quran the sunnah
reading narrations whatever it is
you become almost obsessed with it
and you read everything you can get your
hands on
and this goes on for about one or two or
three days or maybe one or two or three
weeks
and then all of the sudden just as
quickly as it came
you feel if you read another thing
you're going to
you you just have no capacity for
reading anything else
you're just done and then we have this
process continue you either are
sprinting
or you're standing still there's nothing
in between
why does that happen well there's a
number of reasons
but one of the main reasons is that you
are trying to do too much
all at once you are trying to do too
much all at once you have to remember
that your threshold for knowledge
and reading and research and it's it's a
meditation
it's something that is a muscle it
has to be built
and you cannot go to the gym and pick up
power you know all the weights in the
world at once and think that that's the
shortcut there are no shortcuts in
knowledge
the prophet salallahu
only comes by seeking knowledge there's
only one path
to it there's no way to short circuit
that path or to take a shortcut
or cut corners that is not how knowledge
is sought it is something that is a
process
if you try to deviate from that process
you do so at your own peril
and so the process
is if you want this knowledge
then you have to seek it and seeking
knowledge
is something which a person develops
over a period of time it's a muscle
it's your memory actually
which is also very similar to a muscle
and what's interesting about it is once
you develop
that threshold of sitting and studying
and learning
if you can sit for one hour and then two
hours and then three and then
you know all the way up to however many
hours you practice
this is something that you have trained
yourself to do
and if you stop doing it you don't
magically have it forever
no if you stop doing it your muscle
your threshold for study for learning
starts to regress that's how it works
same thing with your memory if you train
your memory
constantly you will become very very
good
at memorizing things quickly and
if you stop practicing you lose your
sharpness
and so if let's say if your threshold
for
studying or reading something is a half
an hour
right then i would say always
stop while you are still
interested never stop once you've
reached your
full threshold so
if your threshold is 30 minutes after 30
minutes you just can't look at a book
anymore
then read for 20 minutes always keep
that flame don't ever exhaust it
always keep it there so that you can
continue to return
and so knowledge is sought
by number one consistency
this is always important
10 minutes a day is better than one hour
a week
10 minutes a day is better than
three hours a month this is not how we
learn we do not learn by
studying all at once and then leaving
everything all at once
we learn by being consistent
second of all intensity is what we are
looking for not extensity
we don't really care how long you study
what we care is how intense that study
is
how collected your mind is when you read
when you are learning third of all you
need to
focus your energy on one thing
you can't just have 20 different books
and read a little bit from every single
book
and become a mile wide and an inch deep
this is not going to
be of consequence to anyone knowledge
that will
fortify you in these times of
uncertainty
and these times of fitnah and these
times of misguidance
where the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam said
hastened to do good deeds before
trials and tribulations will come that
are like
parts of a black and dark night
a person would be a believer in the
morning
and become a disbeliever by night
that quickly the reason for this
is that we are not focusing
and having any depth to our knowledge
unshaken faith comes with
unshaken understanding this is why allah
explains to us
the deeper your knowledge goes the
deeper you are planting that seed in
your heart
and so what is very important
is that a person always
go for depth don't move on to something
else until you've learned
that don't turn the page until you've
understood that page completely if you
read
one page every day great as long as it
is
an intense understanding
the scholars of islam have told us
they give an example of
seeking knowledge an individual who
is hunting
a hunter if you could imagine with
me a hunter goes into
a forest and sees
a sees a squirrel
so he levels his rifle at the squirrel
and then
just as he's going to he has made his
decision
that he's going to have squirrel for
dinner and then he sees
a turkey so then he thinks oh
actually that's better so he
then takes aim at the turkey and then he
sees
a small deer so then he thinks no that's
even better
and just as he's going to the small deer
he sees a buck
and just as he's go that hunter if he
continues on
he is going to go home hungry he will
not have gone home with the buck
nor will he have gone home with the
squirrel
why because one of the worst things that
the human being
can have in his path to knowledge that
will
impede his progress is options
too many options and right now we live
in a time where information is coming at
us with such speed
you can go to a libra you can go to a
bookstore and walk out with thousands of
volumes all at once this is not good for
anyone
because what ends up happening
is you have too many options you end up
never committing to any one of those
options
and so this is how knowledge is sought
this is knowledge people may
you know people may read this and say oh
it's so so dry or it's so
unengaging no it's very engaging it's
just that this
is what knowledge is there is a place
and there is a time for motivational
speeches there's a time for
inspirational quotes
and inspirational stories and there's
also a time for
actually having clear instruction
and this is what these classes are
designed for
and so it's something that takes
patience something that takes
determination
person must always remind himself why it
is he is doing this
now continuing on with the recitation of
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
how did he used to recite the quran
he says
that the prophet muhammad sallallahu
recitation of the quran was an elongated
recitation
at each area he would stop and elongate
those final those final
vowels of the final words of that verse
and so he would recite bismillah
this is how his recitation would be
he says
[Silence]
meaning in prayer would
complete the recitation of al-fatiha
he will say
and if he was reciting surat al-fatiha
right he would raise his voice to say
amin
and those behind him those praying with
him
would as well say
amen with him in a unified voice
so let's take a stop here there's a
great reward for saying amen
the prophet salallahu
[Silence]
he said the imam has been set and
appointed
as the imam in order that he would be
followed in prayer the prophet salallahu
alaihi wasallam says to the companions
hence
[Arabic recitation]
initiate his prayer
and if he recites the quran then be
silent and if he says i mean if he
reaches
the last verse of surat al-fatiha then
you all say
amin what does mean
amin directly translates to
oh allah accept this supplication
allah and so
when a person says
if
it's a supplication it's something that
we're asking from allah
and so when the imam recites it
we finish that dua by saying
meaning allah is
please answer this dua
please grant us what we have asked for
and it's interesting because the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam
said
he says whoever says amin
and his amine coincides
with that of the angels saying amin
then he will be forgiven of his sin
what does that mean well there's a great
reward
in saying amin and so
a person is to say amin just begin
once the imam begins saying amen and to
end with the imam
this is the proper time to say amin
it's been collected in
who was a child in the time of the
prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam he was the first born
in medina in the time of the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam after hijab
and so he did not directly hear
much if anything from the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam
but we consider his narrations the
narrations of companions
because nothing that he heard
is from anyone except for the companions
meaning
all of his teachers are the companions
of the prophet sallallahu alaihi
it's mentioned that when he would
recite in the masjid and lead people in
prayer
when he would say
everyone would say amin along with him
in unisent and the masjid
would almost
shudder with the strength
and the power of that unified unified
voice of amin now who is this who's
saying i mean with him well the scholars
from amongst the companions abdullah ibn
abbas and
right and so
this is how the companions would say
amen
along with the prophet
and unfortunately is one of those things
that
everybody seems to know we should say
but again half knowledge we know we
should say it but we have no idea how
we're supposed to say it
and that is the most dangerous type of
knowledge right
half knowledge is when you when you
neither
understand something nor do you know nor
are you totally
ignorant of it you you think you know
you know just enough to think you know
right this is what is referred to as
compounded ignorance amongst the
scholars of islam
compounded ignorance what is compounded
ignorance
you're ignorant of something and
ignorance of the fact that you are
ignorant of it and so if you go to
in congregation you'll hear all kinds
of things
right it'll almost sound a choir
with everybody saying amin this one says
it after by himself this one says it to
himself this one says it
alone in an extremely high voice out of
unison
from anyone else and this one cuts it
short
and says amin right
and then others say i mean right
and they get very creative all of this
is incorrect
the proper way to say amen with the imam
is that when the imam begins to say
amen then you start with him you never
go before the imam
sometimes you hear people in salah the
imam hasn't even
finished the final syllables of surat
al-fatiha and they're already saying
amin so the imam is
and then people as if you know hurry up
come on we have to say
i mean this is not correct
nor should a person begin amen
before the imam you say it with the imam
and imagine
and so when the imam says amin that is
when the angels say
amen and that is when the followers of
the imam should say
amin and whoever's mean
unifies
and comes in unison with that of the
angels will be forgiven by allah
as the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam has said
another important thing is that when we
say
we say it with elongating
the first two alif
not amin amin means someone who is
trustworthy
someone's name well we don't know who is
amin
amin is not what is
meant what is to be said is
right another thing
is people who go out of their way to
make their voice
unique from amongst the people saying
i mean so you'll have people say amin
and then this guy over here is by
himself screaming
in this pitch or this tone that is
totally off from the rest of everyone
else
this is something which is very very
despised by allah
that an individual stick out from the
crowd
that's not something that allah
subhanahu ta'ala
loves or desires of his servant that in
his worship he tried to
make himself unique in sahih muslim
the messenger muhammad sallallahu alaihi
wasallam
was narrated by saddam nebuchas to have
said
in allah
he says that indeed allah does
love the servant who is contented
who is righteous and who is unnoticed
someone who doesn't try to distinguish
himself from the crowd
and stick out rather a person is just
one of the muslims
he is not looking for attention
[Silence]
and who is a better speech in action
than the one who
calls and invites to allah
does righteous deeds and says
i am one of the believers i am one of
the muslims
so a person is trying to be one of them
he's not trying to be
the one he's trying to be one of them i
am
part of the body of muslims that worship
allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala
indistinguishable to the naked eye only
allah
my lord knows my distinction from those
around me
right
he says what can allah
[Silence]
rebecca he would
be silent for at two points
okay the first point of silence
would be between the initiating techbeef
[Arabic recitation]
and the recitation of the quran in which
he would usually start with
alhamdulillah
rarely with bismillah
and so that's the first time why is that
because that's when he is doing
right we mentioned this we mentioned
the narration of
in which he said to the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam
i've noticed that once you initiate
[Arabic recitation]
between that initiation of tekbir
and the recitation
i've noticed that you
test meaning that you are silent for a
brief moment
before you start your recitation so abu
hurairah says
what is it you are saying during that
time and the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam informed him that that is the
time
when he is making dua and we mentioned
many of the different variants of the
opening dua that the prophet salallahu
alaihi wasallam would make
in initiating his prayer
and so the first moment of silence
in his recitation would be between the
first tech beer
and the beginning of the recitation of
surat al-fatiha this is in the first req
[Arabic recitation]
is then he would begin to recite
right the second time he would make
this silence there is a second silence
it's said that this second silence is
between surat al-fatiha
and the following chapter or verses that
he is going to read
others of scholars say actually
it is between the end of his recitation
[Arabic recitation]
and some scholars said no it's actually
three
moments of pause he would
have that brief silence between the
initiating takbir and surat al-fatiha
then he would have a brief silence
between surat al-fatiha
and the following chapter or verses
and then he would have a third brief
silence between
the end of his recitation before he says
[Arabic recitation]
he says and the correct opinion the
correct
angle to look at this is that it's
actually only twice
the third one which is between his
[Arabic recitation]
is very very brief it's just brief
enough for the imam to be able to catch
his breath
right and those of the companions which
didn't mention this
final silence it's because it is so
brief it's not really considered to be
a moment of silence between recitation
so what does ibn al-qayya mean here
let's unpack that
he means that you begin the way that the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam would
begin his prayer
[Arabic recitation]
there would be a brief silence and then
alhamdulillah that's the first brief
silence
and that's only in the first record then
he would finish the recitation of surat
and then he would say in unison with his
companions
mean and then there would be another
brief silence
that brief silence is to
differentiate between the the surat
and the following chapter or verses that
are going to be recited
then when he would finish his recitation
for that entire
so let's say he's reciting
[Silence]
this is how he would recite that final
silence between
the end of the recitation of the quran
[Arabic recitation]
would be very brief how brief just brief
enough to catch your breath
right and again back to that issue of
half knowledge
people learn this but they don't learn
how to do it
right so what happens
you think the person will be silent so
long that you think that they forgot the
verse
or that they're not done reciting or
that they forgot they're in prayer
you don't know what's going on that's
incorrect it should be very brief
because you don't want it to be
lemiele dwelling
that's not correct you want there to be
a moment of pause
so we would say
just that no more than that any
more than that
is not what the prophet salallahu alaihi
wasallam
would do as if allah mentions here
now with regards to surutil fatiha
which is between that surat al-fatiha
between
amin and the beginning of the next surah
or verses that the imam is going to
recite how long is that
brief pause well it's very brief it's
not
long enough for the person to read surat
al-fatiha
this is an opinion that is considered to
be
kaulun the scholars of filk
view this largely to be
a very weak and undesired opinion an
opinion that has kind of been abandoned
right and that is that the imam should
recite surat al-fatiha
and then he should wait in silence
long enough for the people behind him to
read surat al-fatiha to themselves
this is the weakest of opinions because
we have no evidence that this is
something that the companions already
allowed
would do in this way or that the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam would do
that moment of silence should be just
brief enough
for the imam to decide what he's going
to recite
and for him to differentiate between the
words of the people which is amin
and the words of allah subhanahu
wa'ta'ala which are to follow
now what about the person being led in
prayer
does he have to recite surat al-fatiha
does she have to recite surat al-fatiha
if the imam has recited aloud that is a
very important topic an issue that we
will discuss in our following
in our following installments
of this great series we will discuss it
with a level of depth
inshallah that hopefully people can
understand this issue
it is an issue that many people are very
unclear about
and we hope to clear up any of those
misconceptions in our following
lecture and allah knows best
allah
foreign